you said there's a difference between a
snitch and a rat I didn't know this yeah
so a snitch a snitch is just you did
what you had to do on the outside maybe
you took a deal it's still you'll get a
beat down you'll have to probably be in
protective custody that's what we call
having a jacket and a jacket it means
you have bad paperwork that means you're
either a snitch or you're a uh you know
you've got a crime that's having a
jacket but a rat is is when you're
running in prison working you know doing
dirt and you're informing on you know
your crew and that's going to get you
tagged up that's good you're going to be
killed and that's not just in prison
like you could be a rat out no snitching
on the street it doesn't call
immediately for you getting killed in
prison like if you're a bank robber and
you know you're out there robbing banks
with a dude and you took a deal and
might have informed on them and you go
to prison you hit the yard you might get
a beat down or you might just be shunned
it's not a death sentence if we're
running dope in prison and I get jammed
up and you I tell the whole bro it's a
wrap